all right you wackadoo creatures of the
internet
it's friday and i promised you something
different on friday we are doing
our first ever for guest in remote
location
show and uh it's a crazy day to do it
because there is a lot happening
so joining me today is a journalist wow
i can actually say the word journalist
without going like this
is a journalist and the host of slightly
offensive
on blaze tv elijah shaffer i've got
former lefty knitter turned
walk away all star carlin borsenko and
the willy wonka of politics you know him
michael malus guys welcome to the show
thanks dave thanks dave look at you guys
with your heads
firmly in your boxes this is true
talking head operation we're doing right
now
so uh look there's obviously a crazy
amount going on
and uh elijah i'm going to start with
you because you were on the ground
in the capitol uh you you took some
pictures
uh just in the last i guess two or three
hours you have been banned from
instagram you have been banned from
facebook
uh we also heard that uh carlin who's
been
very heavily involved in in the walk
away movement that the walk away page
has just been taken off
of uh facebook and elijah you just
broke some news like literally like 30
seconds ago about some more censorship
stuff so
take it away yeah that a lot of us are
getting put on no-fly lists
that were i would say just present at
this event
and i'd like to reiterate the fact that
i was not um somehow involved in these
activities i was there reporting
but unfortunately you know this has
become such a serious
reaction and in some ways rightfully so
you would expect the government
to lay a heavy hand on people who breach
a federal building
uh but we're seeing them even you know
not not the government come down on
reporters but big tech has taken a step
outside of the government and they've
essentially taken it
further than what the law wants to take
and they are now deleting
censoring and blocking journalists even
my own personal profiles
that just had pictures of my dog my wife
and my recently
deceased mother you know nothing
political of nature they've just
removed all of the traces of me off
their platforms
uh based off of false accusations by
very far left bloggers that work for
mashable buzzfeed
the daily beast so unfortunately while i
would expect this to be the government
crackdown
we're seeing the alignment of the state
and
the media together into like a state
media run technocracy
and they are using this as a catalyst to
destroy every single person
they possibly can including the
president and i don't think anyone's
safe
including the fact that they're using
this to get a lot of us not to be able
to fly ever again
treating reporters uh journalists and
those documenting
as terrorists it's a really sad day in
our country i'm not scared
i'm overwhelmed though not just for my
own future
but for the future of the country yeah
and just to be clear
you are a credentialed reporter you're
an actual journalist you work at the
blaze it is a place of
journalism you weren't in there breaking
anything did you break anything let's
get you on the record did you break any
windows did you did you flip nancy
pelosi's desk
i didn't break anything i also didn't
touch any federal property besides my
feet on the floor
i did not meddle with anything i did not
tamper with any evidence and in fact
you know nancy pelosi's offices are a
very large swath i want to clarify of
like
10 different chambers i never entered in
her personal
area um and you know ultimately speaking
this is where the police pushed us back
into uh and you know to bring this up i
have a federal congressional press
credential
and so i literally have the legal
authority to operate inside of congress
though i know they broke in
i believe the newsworthiness under the
uh you know the act that was meant to
protect journalists
was very important to let america know
what was happening the police inside the
con
congressional building were
understanding of my credentials and they
worked with me while they arrested the
people around me
they did not arrest me and they let me
leave because they knew i was
documenting the news
and it's really scary to see that just
because my personal political
affiliations and opinions
are against the mainstream of what's
considered tolerable meaning
i still believe in the constitution and
freedom of speech somehow now i'm
getting scapegoated as some procurer of
this violence
when in reality if i wasn't there a lot
of the world probably wouldn't have
known
at least as quickly what was actually
happening right so literally 30 seconds
before we started you
heard this news about the no fly list
carlin apparently you're on this no-fly
list too so
congratulations well i guess so and i
didn't even go in the building
i showed up i significantly after elijah
did i when i came
up to the capitol first off i want to
emphasize there was supposed to be a
scheduled rally
at the capitol after trump's speech
which is why i went
and which is why a lot of other people
went and when i approached the capitol
it was already a giant mass of people
with tens of thousands it looked like a
normal rally
it did not actually click for me that
something was going on
until i was way way into the crowd and i
saw tear gas being shot at them but
i did not go into the building i looked
around outside of the building i
recorded what i could outside of the
building but
i guess i won't be flying anytime soon
we're gonna have to see and can you give
me a quick update on what's going on
with the walk away facebook page so 500
000 people right it's run by brandon
straka
and a couple other people and this is
basically just ex
libs it's ex-libs who just sort of had
it with the democratic party
i know a little something about that and
they just got taken down today
yeah that's exactly what happened it was
about an hour ago we found out that the
walk away group on facebook had been
completely banned it was over 500 000
people
and all of the administrators their
personal pages on facebook have also
been banned and
um and one of the things i want to
emphasize is that there there was
er walkaway approves every single post
that goes up in that facebook group
it's video testimonials of people
talking about why they left the
democratic party so
they review and approve every single one
of them there was no calls for violence
in that group
walk away is a completely peaceful
movement we've been doing rallies around
the country for months
that have been completely peaceful not
one call for violence so if people want
to stay in touch with walk away please
make sure you're going to
walkawaycampaign.com
get on the email list brandon will be
sending out next steps
yeah and i think it's possible they
might be getting on local sometime soon
i might have a little knowledge so
all right malice i know that you'd
rather that i say mean things about you
and troll you and the rest of it but i'm
going to say something nice about you
which is that you
usually are ahead of the schedule on a
lot of this stuff and you've been you
wrote a book called the new right
which i've read and i had you on the
show discuss you've basically predicted
kind of all of everything that's
happened over the last couple years
how you feeling about life right now and
i should note that you are in lockdown
brooklyn
because i'm in lockdown l.a it's like at
least my weather is nice but
you chose brooklyn i'm just curious
what's it going to take for
conservatives to realize that the
constitution is a joke
that the constitutional protections are
going to do nothing to help you
that they are going to come for their
gut your guns regardless of the second
amendment they're going to ban peaceful
assembly regardless of the first
amendment
and you're protecting a document which
is empowering this state
to do things like what you're seeing
it's it's really ridiculous to me
that conservatives still uphold this
document when it's just being used as a
tool of oppression uh
nationwide now to their point earlier
the cathedral wasn't going down without
a fight
by cathedral i mean the arbiters of what
is acceptable establishment
uh discourse in america they are going
to have to
do everything in their power to suppress
and marginalize these alternative
perspectives because the only way they
can maintain
any sort of control is effectively as
a near monopoly so this is an enormous
existential threat to their hegemony
over our culture
i don't and i'm trying to think from
their perspective how would i
try to marginalize or silence 70 million
trump voters and let's suppose other
people who are sympathetic to that
or seek just good from both sides and i
don't see how you do it
because uh historically just finished my
last point historically the left has
said somewhat correctly
that rioting is the voice of the unheard
well when you silence
tens of million people from social media
and tell them to sit down and shut up
and go home
and you make it a felony for them to
leave their house or to earn a living
this is not a recipe for a uniting and
healed nation
so all right so as a guy that's been to
north korea you know a little something
about
authoritarian states like sure are these
the pieces like without being crazy
alarmist and the rest of it i try not to
whip everybody up into a frenzy but like
the pieces that we're seeing fall right
now and the level of
censorship and now no-fly list and the
rest of it like
are we headed there we've been there the
thing is that people had this veneer of
democracy
thinking that oh it's if i hate joe
biden and i think he's a
chinese-owned buffoon if i hate donald
trump and thinks he's a white
supremacist
russian agent why would i need to be
governed by someone i despise this is
the democratic model that people have
been bought into
since kindergarten and now people are
starting to realize since 2020
especially with hashtag not my president
that there this system does not make
sense on any level
and the difference between an
insurrection and a resistance is whether
there's corporate sponsorship
and thankfully conservatives have the
the scales
taken from their eyes and i realized
that corporate america is not their
friend
and corporate america has been much more
effective at imposing maoism
in america than the chinese communist
party ever dreamed of
you mean when i open up hulu and it only
recommends black lives matter things or
i open up youtube and it recommends
black lives matter things or
pretty much playstation and everywhere
else you think you think there's some
corporate entertainment sessions when
you have to get together with like that
law school i think was northwestern
and declare that i am a racist this is
some kind of this is a cultural artifact
of
mao and north korea has it as well and
people need to realize this isn't a joke
that this has been a
soft war and now this war is hardening
as
especially the weakness of the empire
has been exposed
when you have someone who's cast from
burning man able to storm the capital
and slap his member on pelosi's desk
with no pushback
this is not the sign of an empire at the
height of its powers and if you think
someone who crafts his pants at the vice
president's desk for eight years is
going to be the one
who's going to be able to resolve this i
think you're completely delusional
that was about joe biden for the record
um elijah since
elijah since you were there at the
capitol and there's all sorts of weird
video coming out
i played a video yesterday on the show
uh where
it appeared there were literally
thousands of trump supporters at one
point
chanting to stop a guy who they were
saying was antifa from breaking into a
window
now we know plenty of trump supporters
went into the building nobody's denying
that and and that you know offices were
ransacked and whatever else
but can you just talk a little bit about
like the general temperature that was
there and was there a moment that you
saw things go crazy and it almost looked
at times like police
were actually welcoming people into the
building and moving barricades out of
the way and
waving people on and the rest of it can
you just clean it up a little bit from
what you saw
yeah so you kind of hit on everything um
and this is going to probably piss off
anybody who's watching this whether
you're on the left or the right
i think the truth of what happened that
day makes anybody who wants a narrative
to fit
their perfect agenda probably angry and
i'm okay doing that
take a couple people off uh you know
number one i want to say that the
original
altercation of tearing down barriers
people like to see that that was due
to a man having a heart attack i can't
confirm that uh and police not getting
involved and people getting angry
what i saw was a large group of very
very uh
buff uh aggressive young caucasian men
um and they looked like your normal
trump supporters they did not have the
physique that you would experience from
anarchists these were people i was
marching with
up to the capitol for a planned rally
not for some sort of sedition or
insurrection like
lindsey graham is referring to um i did
notice that they were
angry they were saying this is our house
we we we live here we own this
and they started ripping down the
exterior barrier which i believe was the
fourth
uh you know outer barrier that there
were no police actively guarding they
made it to a second barrier as they went
inside so
like it's like whatever going in uh and
they police basically thought that
people would just stop
but they started pushing the barriers of
which one of the gates i
from my footage i believe hit one of the
officers in the head a female officer
almost knocking her unconscious this was
the first major injury i saw of a police
officer
she was stunned and couldn't get up
police began to fight with the
trump supporters this is when there was
about a few dozen already uh people
carrying trump flags
i know people say these are antifa i
will say this uh well i don't have
confirmation of who these individuals
were
i do remember on parlor proud boys were
saying they would dress up incognito
like antifa from taylor hansen and some
other journalists
um and i will say that there was at
least two people that were confirmed
from blm and antifa but of the 12 people
have sent me have been able to
debunk 10 out of 12 of them as not being
from those groups and to kind of speed
this up
police were so firmly and fully
unprepared
for what was about to occur that
essentially uh
essentially what happened was that they
began to fight um the police up front
it turned into serious altercations and
police were cordoned in the middle
and the trump supporters essentially
broke through the sides
of the front line of the police breaking
through
actually maneuvering through the rafters
that were meant for the inauguration on
the upper balcony
and then pushed their way past police
breaking open
quite a few windows and and it appeared
to be like breaking open
doors when i actually arrived to the
front of the capitol building there were
still aids
in their offices evacuating people
holding fire extinguishers at the door
having their doors barricaded um i mean
it was a complete emergency
the people inside were extremely
terrified and my only point is
is that it seemed like once the people
got inside
uh the the area i went to they literally
beat through the cops to get through
people don't like me saying that they
beat up the cops but in another area
that i went to another door
as i was documenting the groups uh
police were actually letting people in
so there was both of that going on in
some entrances police just like welcomed
the people in and took selfies with them
and some of them pulled out guns live
ammunition batons
were beating them up and i saw a lot of
trump supporters get into serious melees
some of which i've seen at other events
before so these were not antiques
these are people's faces i've recognized
from right wing events and i think
you know to put the blame on on on
anybody i would say
to to to try to blame this all on antifa
is intellectually dishonest
and a lot of the people pushing those
lies are just grifters no i i
and that's why i wanted to ask you the
question and actually that's a perfect
segue because carlin you were basically
put on the map because you were a
lifelong lefty you went to a
a trump rally and you realized that it
was actually nice decent people who were
happy and everything
else and as you know over the last
couple months i went to a bunch of trump
rallies
i never saw one iota of negativity i saw
happy people proud
of their country joyous gay straight
black white blah blah blah
blah did you see anything while you were
there that that
led you to believe this was a different
group either left right doesn't matter
but did you did you get a sense like oh
something ain't right here well i you
know
i was outside the building right and i
got there after everyone else and when i
got there
people were sitting on the lawn having a
great time they were waving american
flags they were chanting usa usa usa
like it really the experience i had with
it is i did not witness
any of the violence i didn't even know
what was happening until
later when i got back to the hotel i
mean i was even texting you dave and i
was like and you you said something
about the violence i was like what are
you even talking about i have no idea
you literally didn't know yeah yeah no
because none of us had any service so we
couldn't get the news we couldn't get
twitter updates we didn't know what was
going on so
the vast majority of people i believe i
i think it is a
it is really dangerous that all of the
people there are being cast under the
same brush because the vast majority of
people
were there a because there was a
scheduled event there b
they were there to stand up and demand
that their voices be heard
not through violence but by being
present and demanding accountability
from their elected officials and i think
what we need to keep in mind is this is
a group of people that has been
emotionally abused by every major
institution
in this country for five years called
every name in the book censored banned
fired from their jobs
these are people that were afraid of
wearing a red
hat outside of their house and
you know you can only push people so far
before something happens
and that was how it manifested itself
but for the vast majority of people that
were there
they did not go in the building they did
not destroy property they were there
peacefully sitting on the grass
chanting usa usa usa malice i assume
that the reaction from the mainstream
media immediately calling this an
insurrection and a white supremacist
rally and the rest of it
uh from the very same people who were
actually instigating
black lives matter and antifa rallies
for the last two years
um i assume that didn't surprise you did
it surprise anybody
i mean this this the the entire job of
the corporate press is to train
blue-pilled people and how to perceive
and emotionally respond to various
events that they see
uh on their their screens and so forth
so i'm not surprised no slightest this
is their role
and i disagree a little bit with carlin
it's like she makes the point like for
five years they were called every name
in the book
you know nazi white supremacists
whatever and i think there's
still a little bit of expectation on
some people on the right that well i
didn't go in the building so i could
expect to be treated fairly
why why would you expect a group of
people
who want you dead but will settle for
your submission to treat you with any
kind of decency
where your existence is a threat to
their domination and control
they will do everything in their power
to marginalize you and
ruin you and you have to start with that
as the point
and any expectation to the contrary i
don't think ports to reality
so i know that people watching this that
get what you're saying like they get it
like okay they're not going to make any
distinction whether you were
peaceful or not peaceful or there or not
there or anything else but i know a lot
of people watching that are going man
i don't want to live in that world
they're they're just afraid of living in
the world that you're laying
what do you do with that what are you
doing go to mars leave the earth call
elon musk
um i mean it's it's it's really
this has been the status quo for a very
long time and now
thankfully thanks to social media they
can't
hide behind their lies and you could see
again like we were saying last year
like the black lives matter the voice of
the unheard or cnn was being burnt down
just tell them the insurrection was
mostly peaceful and that'll get them to
uh
shut up a little bit use their language
but there's no talking this is
a uh nra the nra was being called
terrorists
openly and brazenly kamala harris was
saying the president should be kicked
off of twitter
uh so i think we're going to see
hopefully an increasing intellectual
self-segregation our nation
there's no reason for everyone to be on
facebook i made this point with you on
your show previously
in the same way there's no reason for
everyone to be on okcupid or
on one of these or any of these other
apps we are going to have to
intellectually self-segregate
before our nation hopefully breaks up in
the very near future
i believe it's malice.locals.com
yes sir and i believe it's
carlin.locals.com no
kb because it's impossible to spell for
most people
and of course elijah so you so you're on
the blaze and i i'm also on the blaze
and
that offers us some protections but as
you said you just got booted from
instagram you just got booted from
facebook now there's a freaking no-fly
zone you also told me your your youtube
was
demonetized right but you're still on
youtube all monetary
uh gains away from the channel yes so do
you have backup plans i mean i think
everyone's
looking at people like us going okay you
guys are sort of the public face of what
we're dealing with privately right like
they're either stopping posting where a
lot of people are deleting their
accounts
i i mean literally in the last two days
i've lost 10 000 twitter followers it's
not that
suddenly people don't like me it's it's
accounts that are being banned or
or just nuked whatever it is but do you
do you have any plans like
what do you think about this idea that
michael has thrown out there of this
sort of intellectual segregation and
we just got to take care of ourselves
and and maybe just get off all of these
things
these big platforms well yeah it's
absolutely true you know i think that we
all just stay on as long as we can and i
agree with
with michael and the fact that you know
i want to reiterate two sides of this
i mean the trump supporters that are
that are denying that trump supporters
could do this
i mean do you not have you not heard the
sentiments from people who follow trump
i mean they are
pissed they are upset i mean they have
been absolutely berated
with and dehumanized d person d platform
the people they love have been
completely obliterated off of any
ability for them to access information
they've been ostracized oftentimes lost
their jobs
they've been alienated from families i
mean you know we talk about all this and
everyone agrees yeah that's how trump
supporters feel and it's like you don't
believe that that could
end badly that people could revolt that
that you how did the revolution
happen how did these things occur which
is where people gave criticisms to me
that oh you used the term
revolutionaries you were
supporting a revolution or a coup i said
no when you're in
a group of people that are chanting
revolution and
many of which were calling for the for
the termination of life of some congress
members
that's not a popular thing to say i
voted for trump i don't want to believe
that people are you know around me or
try to make anyone look bad
i don't do that on the left either i
don't go to a left-wing rally and try to
make blm look bad
i just take people what they say and i
put it out there and i'm saying
people are angry and when they look at
us being taken down it's not just the
figureheads
they're being taken down too and i think
that the tech companies are not
realizing the damage this is going to do
because
you know i i do i do have to watch a lot
of things that i might say because i
have to follow
uh tech guidelines but if you push
people like you they did to alex jones
into band.video
where he's on his own servers well i
think his rhetoric actually gets more
extreme it gets more unhinged and it
gets more out of control
and i think what they're doing is
creating they're creating a greater
enemy than they're actually preventing
and they're taking normal people who
have traditional right-wing views like
myself
who work a normal job reporting that are
out there and they make us
seem to be like we're complicit in some
terroristic activities that we are evil
people
i'm going to push back for one second
about jones because we had on msnbc
and i think was on cnn during the last
year william weld
former governor of massachusetts saying
that president trump committed treason
and in his words he had said
and the penalty for treason is death
when you have people
on the air calling for the president to
be killed
there is nothing alex jones that king
said has come close
uh to that kind of rhetoric and they
have no consequences for their behavior
and just one more quick point
everyone earlier in 2020 who said if we
didn't go into syria boots on the ground
this is another holocaust that this is a
genocide
and the extermination of the group
people over there no one had any
consequences for wanting american
soldiers to be murdered for no reason
but michael i'm not i'm not saying that
alex is more extreme than these people
i'm saying that they're saying oh we
need to hold these people accountable so
the best way we can hold them
accountable
is to then boot them off of the public
forum oh and then i'm saying that i'm
saying that
actually the people they're booting
saying we're too extreme are actually
very respectful of their guidelines and
of their rules
which makes you question why are we
still even respectful why are we
operating in these platforms because
realistically speaking they operate in
these platforms with complete immunity
they yeah believe me the amount of
people that have wrote me even public
people saying they want to kill my wife
they want to kill me pee on our graves
terrible things are there accounts down
no
shutdown dc called for violence in dc in
the capital
is there a count that's a black lives
matter group are they shut down
no i'm just saying that my point is is
not that they're not
under different rules but it's just that
as they push people
offline then they complain oh now
everybody's talking unhinged on parlor
and it's like
well why is everyone on parlor it's
because you've pushed people off your
platforms and then you're complaining
that you don't have control of them
anymore well now you realize you're just
tyrants you're not looking for peace on
your platform looking to control
all conversation in all of society and
they're not going to stop until they
have that
so did you guys read a book about that
someone should write a book about that i
think i have it over here
um did you guys happen to see that this
morning dan bongino who created parlor
and who
helped create rumble um that he
has officially said he's not going to
use twitter anymore that he's said i've
built some stuff
and i'm going to stay over there and i'm
going to get off this thing michael do
you think that seeding the ground
is the right way to go that actually
look i i started locals
it's exploding right now which i'm
thrilled about and i would welcome
everybody
to get on there and see what we're doing
and create your own community and be
free
but do you think that ultimately i think
i think you sort of said it already that
that we have to just create our own
things and just and just let them go
just the disconnect
i'm an anarchist which means i'm for
peace and for freedom of association
and i agree that you have to fight where
you can but
you should expect that they are going to
ratchet up
the um blocking and banning people as
much as possible
and it's same thing you have a fire
extinguisher uh you know if
i get kicked off of facebook if i get
kicked off of youtube
this is why i do have my locals and
other uh kind of outlets because
you have to expect that they're not
going to go down without a fight
and anyone who is a threat to their
monopoly control of discourse
they are going to treat as a threat and
you have to anticipate these actions
accordingly
carlin what are you hearing just from
regular people because i think what's so
interesting about your story is you had
nothing to do
with any of this literally a year and a
half ago
like the the three of us like we've been
in this for a while but you were
you were a knitter i was knitting dave i
was knitting a year and a half ago
and and and i will say that ravelry i
actually had a knitting group that i
recently created on ravelry called
crafting rebels and
my knitting group has been banned on
ravelry as of yesterday
with no explanation so the knitters are
still at it but
no i i have been inundated with emails
and messages from people
uh basically saying that they had the
same experience at the capitol that i
did that they did not realize that there
was violence they did not realize what
was going on they were
sitting around having a good time and
you know peacefully expressing their
first amendment rights and they are
floored at what's happening and it's
like it is overwhelming to me it is
overwhelming that in a country where
we watched for months as black lives
matter and antifa
rioted lit fires up and down the streets
in every
in all these major cities including
washington dc
and we're told that this was a peaceful
protest peaceful protest peaceful
protest should be uncomfortable dave
don't you know that protest should be
uncomfortable
and we had to watch this there was one
trump rally where things got admittedly
out of hand and i think
you know i have condemned the violence
many people have condemned the violence
and it just doesn't matter
it doesn't matter so elijah as a
journalist without air quotes
this this idea that basically everybody
on the right i mean
everybody condemned the violence there
is nobody that didn't condemn the
violence
but it never gets condemned and not only
doesn't get condemned but you guys
probably saw that super cut
on twitter where people were showing all
of the lefty
journalists uh an msnbc host on the rest
of it you know that
that incredible ali velshi video with a
firebomb exploding behind him saying
it's a mostly peaceful protest
i guess you're not surprised by the way
the media has treated this
no i'm not i'm not surprised at all
actually because
i firmly believe that you know if blm or
if anybody had been in this situation
right if
it had been a white cop shooting an
unarmed black woman inside even if she
was invading
this would have been the idea of look
the state from the highest level down
is destroying our lives that the
narrative i don't understand it fully
but the narrative would have been
different
um the reason why even after condemning
this
what's shocking to me about the reaction
to this is that
this is not really any less severe than
anything i've experienced over the last
nine months across in the entire year
almost of 2020
i've seen much worse than this that's
all i'll say i've seen
much worse than this and i've seen much
less
condemnation the best example is kenosha
kenosha was a terrorist attack on
domestic soil they burned down
uh they and destroyed over three third
36 i think buildings
they destroyed uh like tens of millions
of dollars in personal property
they were pulling out guns they were
destroying so much public property you
can't even fathom
and they were burning down apartment
buildings with children inside
this is how intense it was and what does
the final narrative come from kenosha
it's the debate about whether kyle
rittenhouse is a white supremacist or
not
nobody debates about the terrorist
attack that happened on domestic soil
nobody cares the argument is just about
the narrative of this one kid and these
shootings that took place
on you know a few days after all the
violence began
and so i don't want to hear it from
people you know they don't care that we
condemn the violence that's what the
right wing or the conservatives don't
understand
you can't remedy your position on this
you can't be right
because it's not a game set up to where
you can ever win
they will always be right because they
control the institutions
we will always be wrong and as we cow
toe back and try to pretend
like we try to you know create these uh
you know
press releases and try to explain our
stance in the end we just end up looking
weak to our base
while at the same time showing the left
they actually have more power to weaken
and destroy our stance
and there's if you condemned or you
condoned this event
you're going to be persecuted either way
that's it's a losing game
malice i i couldn't see you because we
had the camera just on elijah but i have
a feeling you were like praising god as
he was talking right there because
that's your whole point right
praising someone let me read that aoc
tweet this is from december 2nd 2020.
remember 2020 we were so much younger
then
uh the whole point of protesting is aoc
is to make people uncomfortable
activists take that discomfort with the
status quo and advocate for concrete
policy changes
popular support often starts small and
grows to folks who complain
protest demands make others
uncomfortable that's the point
i agree with everything elijah just said
and i'm delighted
that so many people on the right are
realizing uh stop apologizing
stop trying to fight on a turf that you
cannot possibly win
these people are not playing fair they
just want your submission
uh if they can have that if not they
will just do everything they can to
destroy your life as being a threat to
their power
and i'm shocked by how many
conservatives who i'd written off
as almost entirely delusional have uh
become
aware of this new reality and i'm sure
these lockdowns certainly helped open
their eyes at large to a large extent
yeah malice what do you think of biden
and kamala
saying that if this had been black
people it would have been very different
it would have been very different they
would have been shooting people on the
streets and everything else
even though we know that uh
the rioters as elijah just laid out have
destroyed kenosha have destroyed we
don't even talk about that we have
destroyed seattle right we don't even
talk about it yeah
hold on the media basically treats us
like six months ago doesn't exist and
the narrative is whatever on your screen
in june they strong the white house
black lives matter store in the white
house they brought the barricades as
everyone knows the white house has
snipers on the roof they have people all
over to protect the president whoever
that happened be
no one was killed no one's shot so we
don't have to even speculate
we had a group of largely people of
color storming the white house
and none of them were murdered so any
claims to the contrary is a complete lie
now maybe kamala harris telling the
truth because as a cop if she was in
charge she'd be mowing people down
because that's her wet dream
but that's another issue and the other
thing that's great c-span which is a
non-partisan organization which puts
political speeches for everyone's
edification online
uh when she was making that claim that
clip she got ratioed on twitter and when
you ratio a tweet
that means there's more comments than
likes which is a good indicator that
this tweet is uh
did you use joe biden's term malarkey
right of course the
bigger issue is that our days of being
able to ratio things
is is probably coming to a close but uh
we'll
we'll deal with that let's shift a
little bit here because i'm really
curious for
the three of you guys who are in this
thing and it comes with some benefits
right people dig us and say nice things
to us and
and help support us and all that but i
know that it comes with
a certain cost too because you know like
the hate
the the personal stuff you know i got
just yesterday david david literally
had a friend uh text him and basically
say what's it like to be married to a
terrorist talking about me a lifelong
friend saying that
um and i have no doubt that you guys are
dealing with your own versions of all of
that kind of crazy i didn't know you got
your pilot's license even wow that's
amazing
you're good now this you're good um but
but for real like
can you guys just talk about just like
the personal cost of of
being in this carl and i'll start with
you first cause i think you
out of all of us probably expected it
the least yeah i mean i
i have been denounced by every single
one of my former friends in the last 24
hours and
you know what i i kind of reached a
breaking point with all of this when i
was at a like
when i was peacefully expressing my
first amendment rights to be denounced
by
every single person who used to call me
a friend i just started responding with
i got chased by a mob of black lives
matter in dallas
several months ago where were you then
if you don't show me the receipts of you
denouncing that
then i do not care what you have to say
and that is the point that i'm at with
us
yeah elijah i know uh you know i know
you just lost your mom i know you're
you're getting hit on all fronts and and
quite literally you got attacked
wait which was that just a couple weeks
ago you were physically attacked i mean
we all saw the bloody pictures of your
face i mean you've had you've had a real
personal
and and professional cost yeah and i i
you know greta thunderberg always says
how dare you but i honestly love that
quote
because it's like how dare you to the
media to talk about me being
sympathetic with people being you know
violent in cases where
you know people don't want violence to
occur i mean i'm a victim of
constant political violence i'm in the
midst of every single one of these
things and the media has
never come to my aid never cared when
i've been attacked never
written anything about when i've had
guns pointed at my head or i've been
jumped i've gotten a concussion i've
gotten my leg broken by the department
of homeland security in portland last
year
and the most important part about all of
this is that the media has been
completely silent
and they haven't cared i mean the amount
of death threats that are in my life
right now in the fbi speaking of that
probably will be contacting me soon
maybe
but they already have been contacting me
because there's been you know active
assassination attempts in washington dc
where were the politicians talking about
in condemning the political violence of
people trying to kill right-wing
journalists or conservative journalists
they didn't care because they actually
want me dead i believe that
they're happy when i get beat up if they
can't hurt me into submission
then they will be happy if someone else
kills me into into submission
because ultimately speaking it they have
right now they are messaging my family
they're messaging my friends my church
it is so disgusting
to the extent that these professionals
have gone to to completely destroy and
defame my life
they should be ashamed of themselves and
i'm glad i believe in god
unlike michael because their need hell
needs to exist for people like this
malice i'm going to let you close it out
but i'll just say on my front beyond
like the personal
stuff and losing friends and even family
members that are angry me i mean i've
got cameras in every freaking room in my
house
we've got huge fences outside of my
house that we just expanded like i've
been doxxed and
all of that crazy stuff like this comes
with a cost
uh what about for you on the personal
side and br bring us home
bring us home
if i'm if i can use this word i'm the
biggest of us for
us for i've been choosing my battles i
have not been in the front lines
um and i've not so you know thank you to
you guys for taking the shots but
i coming from being born in russia being
raised in a russian household
uh i'm very aware of what people are
capable of uh what people with a little
bit of power will be willing to do with
those who threaten them in the slightest
and it's very unfortunate that you know
people like elijah and karlin
as americans are starting to learn the
consequences of what it means when power
has no restrictions well listen guys
uh this was our first test and i got to
tell you i i seriously enjoyed this i it
was it was
it was fun but you know i know there's
like some serious stuff going on right
now and it's crazy and i love being in
the fight
and i it is going to get worse i mean
that's the thing that's the thing every
everywhere i go people say to me dave
when does this stop when does this stop
and i always say it's going to get worse
before it gets better and the question
is
the question is what is rock bottom and
i i don't think we really want to think
about it i mean it's it's
i try not to depress people at the end
of these shows what are we doing here
somebody say something good quick i mean
i think that there's hope
i think that there's hope when we reach
rock bottom because that gives people a
chance
to build back up again i think that if
there's blessings in everything right
you can always look at things negatively
or you can look at them positively and i
think that we can look at this situation
and see that a giant
light has been shown for a lot of people
to reflect the things that michael's
been talking about
for a very long time this has now been
made real for a lot of people
and we we had no hope of even attempting
to fix this problem
if that light hadn't existed so we
should maybe be thankful for that it's
going to suck for a while but
at least at least it was made to appear
carl and borisenko finishing strong
follow her at kb.locals.com
follow malice malice.locals.com slightly
offensive on blaze tv for elijah shaffer
and and guys check out locals i mean
we're all going to be banned soon enough
so so
find some of the people you like and
figure out where you can follow them off
the big tech stuff
guys this was great i think i'm going to
try to do this every week and i hope
you'll be part as much as you can
and i consider you all friends and
allies and all that good stuff
and have a nice non-political weekend